happy New Year everyone how's it going
welcome to the across the Spoilers
Podcast so glad you could join us hope
you enjoying 2024 already be honest in
the comments below how long have you
gone yet without being nasty to someone
and arguing on Twitter I'm trying as
hard as I can right now to not get in
any any BS with anyone but uh we'll see
we'll see how it goes Greg how's it
going with you it's going well Paul it's
great to see you after Christmas how was
your Christmas how is your how's your
family how's your hot wife how's
everything going it's go it's all going
pretty good to be honest it was nice
actually just taking some time out and
just being like you know what I'm not
going to cover every episode of what if
I'm going to just do the ones from five
onwards and have a bit of a chillax on
it you know do they still say chillax
the kids I don't know yeah they do will
speaking of what if we are getting into
that right now what did you think of
season two Paul you and I have been here
many times saying what is Disney doing
why are they releasing this at this
specific time don't they realize they
are ruining our holidays specifically
us I was pleasantly surprised by how
enjoyable that what if show was I
thought it was so fun so much better
than season one and yes the finale I I
see that there's been some discourse
with it and I am uh we I think I I saw
some of your video this morning at the
time we're recording this I saw some of
your video and based off of the comments
I was like okay yeah Paul and I have
some similar opinions when it comes to
criticisms but I still even then I was
like yeah that's still a really fun
finale in spite of some narrative things
that occur there uh overall though I was
pleasantly surprised man I liked it so
much more than I was expecting to I just
could not believe how much better it was
no I really you know as much as we were
angry about the release schedule
watching it how it was released I
thought this is a really fun way to
enjoy it and I had said before It All
released that I wasn't going to bother
covering any of it but I started
watching it and I'm thinking you know
what I'm I'm I am going to cover this
but I'm going to wait until there's at
least some connectivity and and I'm not
killing myself or missing out on
anything that I wanted to do in order to
cover it so spoke to my friend MO who
got it early he seen them all and he was
like episodes five six eight and nine
they're all connected so I thought you
know what I'll I'll do those episodes
and I'll just lock them in Mt can you do
episode seven he's done that so we we
had a nice little run of it um I did
enjoy the season I did think the finale
fell very short though and it was purely
the character twist with Doctor Strange
supreme or whatever he's strange Supreme
I'll call him um I always think of like
a supreme pizza from Pizza Hut whenever
I say that but I did think the car turn
was a bit out of nowhere you know if
they had have teased it throughout the
season I think that I would have been
more on board with it but every time we
was showing up in a post credit SC he
was like how are you doing guys what's
happening
um and then for it to be to turn out he
was the bad guy it felt a bit like
Daenerys in Game of Thrones where it's
just like really fun and bubbly one
second evil the next and I don't fully
understand what the plan was because I'm
pretty sure that he could have powered
up the forge anyway without having to
get kahori he could have just got
someone else um So the plan was get
kahori for the forge and then have to
get captain Carter because kahori will
know that he's guy and fight him so it's
better to sending her or something
doesn't make sense to me that plan um
and I was kind of thinking what is the
wh if of this finale you know what I
mean like what is the actual what if
that's going on here it just seems like
a big fight that's a fair point that's a
fair point good from an action point of
view story-wise not too sure on it but
overall I think the season was fantastic
a great Step Up of uh season one die
hard that die hard episode loved it and
I was just coming off the back of
something that I should hate die hard
for guys because you know that diod
video on the channel right now it took
three days after we edited it all to get
it online because it just kept getting
flagged and normally yeah when you
upload a video one you'll get a 7c claim
and you just have to go back and edit
all these parts try and re-upload it and
what'll happen is you'll get keep
getting hit with these 7c claims and
eventually you'll get to a point where
all those 7c claims have been re-edited
now this was going through the 7c ones
5c getting it down it finally got down
to 3 seconds and I just thought I'm
going to try five more uploads and if I
don't get it on this one it's been three
days 60 attempts at it after I've
already paid all the editors to edit the
entire thing we're just I'm just going
to leave it so it was a bit down on that
Greg but to see that episode it just it
was so good and just coming off the back
of obviously spending a a lot of time
with Die Hard just the little subtle
things I did in I thought were really
good so even just Darcy stepping out and
turning and looking up at Avengers Tower
was playing on Al Al Powell stepping out
of the the gas station and just looking
up at the top of the tower and seeing
like the the little Sparks on top of it
really good um I think the nebula
episode about Blade Runner that was that
was brilliant
um yeah just a solid season I'm rcking
my bright 1602 as well love that graphic
novel definitely check it out if you
guys like that episode it's by Neil
Gaiman who's a fantastic writer um and
yeah just to see that I like how every
season they kind of take um an already
established elseworld story and kind of
make that into an episode like season
one we had the zombies one and then this
season 1602 yeah yeah great I think the
nebula one starting off with that
immediately set the ground of oh this is
going to be a different season right
away I loved it so much I was blown away
and I was thinking okay is this just
going to be the is the first episode
going to be the one where they do
something really cool and then after
that it's going to just dip back to what
season one was and they kept just
surprising me throughout and I think
through the I I honestly think the
Steven strange argument is going to be
going on for quite a while because that
finale I'll just say this I I had just
the inverse experience of what I've
heard with people who really like the
Marv in a way of yeah they can like
there's people who watch the Marvels and
go I see a lot of the flaws however uh I
still had a lot of fun with it and I
wasn't one of those people I am one of
those people when it comes to this wh if
finale because I thought like visually
it's still very impressive and I see the
arguments that I even said it in my
video of yes it does make sense actually
that this guy would not get over Steven
Strange's stubborn as he is like even
though he did have a character Arc in
season one as stubborn of an individual
as he is that that realistically yeah he
would not get over um the death of
Christine after that whole obsessive
path that he went through I I completely
see the the argument for that I believe
the validity of it is what I'm saying I
just think narratively throughout the
season they didn't really set that up
that it was going to come back in some
capacity if that makes sense and then
when you're the argument for realistic
portrayal of grief like but you also
have like insane unrealistic things
happening the entire time so you can't
so you can't really pick and choose your
battles of well no that's realistic but
then you got like other things that are
like so hyper
unrealistic that are happening
throughout because then you see
different justifications for why you
know uh Captain Carter is able to become
just insanely powerful uh throughout and
then you know I get it at this a lot of
times I just go yeah I get it you know
it's it's a half hour show so you can't
really build up to some of these things
uh however you know man I I keep going
back to the the age-old excuse for any
comic book property
shortcoming it was so much fun it was I
I had such a BL because it's visually
beautiful to look at and that's the
thing with Marvels that I couldn't even
get on board with uh not not to only
compare it to that but that was the
thing of why I would say I could walk
away saying that finale I had so much
fun with even though I could see some of
its shortcomings because it was still
dazzling to witness uh you know on my
television screen so yeah yeah I think
they just kind of shw the kitchen sink
and the entire house at everything for
the finale and it just that doesn't
necessarily interest me that much when
it's the same with the secret Invasion
finale it just gets to a point when
you've got every single power and it
just all the powers negate each other
and it's just kind of just flashing
light on on screen rather than being
that they're being Stakes so even people
out thinking the C A Certain situation
Iron Man one great example get set up
earli in the film if you fly too high
the suit gets frosted over can't handle
the ice that sort of thing and then it
it pays off later in the end you know
the dark
night I know how you got these scars
he's got the little bat rang things that
come out of his wrist I like when fights
are set up like that whereas it's just
just kind of every single power doesn't
matter what it is just keep throwing it
and keep shooting each other with the
lasers and that's that's it and
eventually one of you will break through
and yeah I did feel like it fell apart
in terms of that the thing that I think
they're missing with Captain Carter and
I am curious to know what the comment
would say about this the the main
element that I think they're missing
with Captain Carter and I they only just
introduced Kori I'll use the exam okay
okay so Captain Carter the alternate
version of Captain America you know the
the whole I can do this all day thing
the reason why that quote stands out so
much even though Captain America is
super powerful he's a super powerful guy
and he's fast and everything he's got
agility not like Quicks Quicks over or
anything but you know what I mean uh he
usually says that when he's beaten up he
usually says I can do this all day when
he is struggling when he is like on on a
Lifeline you could tell he's exhausted
uh that's why we root for Daredevil in
that hallway fight because even though
yeah he's powerful he's got hide in
sentence whatever is because he's he's
like on the verge of death you know and
even though we know Captain America
won't die it is that physical exhaustion
that is all over like whether he's
bloodied up and messed up but even in
the wh if season I don't feel like a lot
of that criticism was warranted towards
Hela even though we know she's
introduced as a God so you got that
eliminated right away but what I
actually respected about it this is
going to come across a little weird is
that when she's introduced in that show
and she gets to earth like she's getting
her ass kicked like there's when she
starts in a fight like just fre l in the
face and you see her have to earn her
way back up and become a skilled Warrior
again and I feel like that's what with
the missing ingredient is with um with
uh Peggy Carter in the show because I
think Haley Atwell is extremely Ching
actor and I and I like Captain Carter
but there that that is that I cry every
time I say that Union Jack Greg as soon
as I say that un Jack screen finally got
a hero representation uh yeah no man I
that's the one quality there because
even Kori I thought was a very I loved
her episode love the world and and and
with it being a half hour show you don't
really get time to you know demonstrate
a lot of the if you're going to make
someone super powerful you have you you
do have to introduce some element of of
physical struggle along the way and and
I think sometimes Marvel does shy away
from that with certain female characters
you know but that's why I was using Hela
as a comparison I'm like no that's what
was really cool about her I was watching
the struggle that she had so well every
writer out there in Hollywood knows that
Mary Sue is a Trope and I would put if I
was writing something from you know I
might not be the best person to write
things from a female perspective but I
would actively try and avoid going into
tropes that I already knew and with that
being such a that gets levied in so many
videos at the moment and and so many
discussions and I personally would
actively avoid it Captain Carter you
know I love her um I don't really see
that myself but if people are levying
that criticism I can totally see it from
their point of view and I think the
internet in general we kind of have hit
a point where there's very little nuance
and very little people willing to agree
that there there's Shades of Gray in any
issue it's it's very much black or white
it's you are on this side or you're on
that side and we get called it all the
time we'll get called woke and then
we'll get called racist and sexist for
for doing like saying that we didn't
like something and it's like guys come
on you guys shouting W about everything
are just as bad as you guys shouting
racist and sexist about everything these
are both totally missing the the shades
of grain and argument and seeing the new
ones there it's just very binary for you
guys where it's it shouldn't be and
there should be discussions about how
things are handled and it's totally fine
to to say like you don't think a
character was handled as well as it
could have been without being labeled
the worst person in the world you know
what I mean Greg and I think I think
overall you know I do think they dropped
the ball a bit on the finale I feel like
they didn't really know where to go with
it whereas in season one they had a much
stronger finale but I think the episodes
preceding the finale in season two were
vastly outweighed what they gave us in
season one so overall strong season um
and I I think this year if you know we
were talking about this the other day if
Marvel had a released um Guardians of
the Galaxy Loki and what if they would
have been seen as having a really strong
year and I think even if they'd released
Quantum Mania it would have been an L
but I think people would have gave them
the pass on that and been like yeah
Marvel have still had quite a good year
but it was secret Invasion that really
annoyed people um and the Marvels as
crazy even now I see people talking
about it which is kind of an opposite to
our next topic which is Aquaman which
hasn't really had the blowback and
there's been blowback that there hasn't
been enough blowback about it you guys
haven't given this you get you guys were
writing hundreds of Articles like I've
seen people tweeting variety all the
time saying you guys are writing
hundreds of articles about how than the
Marvel's bomb but you haven't touched
Aquaman once and I think it's at this
point like everyone expected Aquaman
bomb I mean I don't know how long ago on
the podcast we were calling it but I'm
pretty
sure every time we've talked about
Aquaman it's been uh it's been saying
the movie is not going to do well but we
did see the writing on the wall with it
so there was no red carpet Premiere
which even I can't understand that I
mean I remember in the strikes people
like well I can't have Premier they
can't have actors out there promoting it
but to not give the sequel to a billion
dollar film a red carpet
Premiere like I don't even hear of most
movies not getting red carpet premieres
I thought that was just a standard thing
that you guys all agreed to and came out
to do um and yeah I've said for a while
that I think in general audiences on the
whole tend to prefer comic book movies
that take themselves seriously and after
this year I'm even more convinced I tell
you what Greg if I hear another comic
book movie being described as fun and
wacky in the buildup to it I'm going I'm
going to bloody kill someone and it
might be you Greg because you're the
closest person right now so I'm hoping
that this this shows the studios you
know we need to go back to taking these
things seriously if you look at all the
the highest grossing films like Avengers
endgame takes itself very seriously
Infinity War takes itself very seriously
even Captain Marvel was kind of
criticized for you know her being quite
a d personality in it um you know black
panther takes itself very seriously The
Dark Knight trilogy all that takes
itself very seriously and weirdly ever
since Guardians of the Galaxy though
that was a big hait and this is another
thing i' I've repeated on the podcast
several
times Guardians of the Galaxy was the
best and worst thing that happened to
Marvel because it made them think that
they could make a a film out of any hero
but it also made them think we can make
a film out of any hero and sometimes you
know that's not always a good thing
because these characters aren't popular
enough to carry a big film and get money
back from it so yeah it's been a bit of
a weird one so have you did you ever get
around to seeing it I no I've been way
too busy I I mean I had I covered all
what if I was under the impression that
I would be here talking about what if
with you and you would have have seen it
and then you would have seen Aquaman and
I wouldn't have seen it I'm like oh cool
we're both taking care of one side of
the equation here that's not the case
obviously no I mean I I had to uh work
on the edits for what if and um Rebel
Moon as well so it was just I was just
way too busy and you know how like I I
could watch it but at this point I'm
like I might as well just wait for it to
come out on on demand just do a video
then so I think the Studios have
probably learned a very hard lesson this
year about what they need to do in the
future and how expensive these things
are because you know when things are all
sunshine and rainbows and they're making
money and getting audiences in yeah sure
green light at 250 million dollar film
but when they're not it's it's very
difficult to to justify constantly
making these types of films I mean Greg
I probably made more this year than
Warner Brothers did with four DC movies
you know what I mean the people
listening to this they'll have made more
money than Warner Brothers did on DC
this year because apparently they lost a
billion dollars from doing it so as long
as you guys didn't lose a billion
dollars even if you only
made1 or $10 this year you made more
than Warner Brothers they should have
just took that money Greg and just put
it on the put it on right at the casino
um but yeah it like we were I remember
earlier in the a we were talking about
Oppenheimer and kind of like wow it's a
hundred million and it look how good it
is and it's three hours long and I
started thinking why are superhero
movies so expensive to make and that is
the obviously the danger that the risk
that comes with them that there's not
much risk when they're making money and
hand over fist and everything and you
you're just raking it in but when we
have a year like what we just had it's
it's crazy that they spend this much
money when you can make Oppenheimer for
$100 million but I started thinking
about it and if you've ever watched one
of those behind the scenes things that
Marvel do it's you can start to see why
it actually costs so much and a good
example a couple of good examples that I
of have you ever saw the behind the
scenes for Captain Marvel when she sat
in the
jet everything even the visor CGI and if
you you see it without it's all just a
big green screen shot and for example in
far from home if you ever saw a moment
where Nick Fury's just sitting in his
chair and he's got the gun that he's
shot Ned with the the gun CGI the B the
wallpaper CGI I started realizing
Christopher Nolan what he does he I mean
Oppenheimer takes place on sets and
locations and I there's not much he said
there's like no CGI in the movie right
so they build the set or they either go
to the location where it is they make
the costumes they film it that's it when
you're doing everything on green screen
then every single shot in your film
becomes a VFX shot and you have to make
every single shot in your film go to an
effect company to sort it out and I just
started thinking that that is why the
the budgets are so high because even if
you go back to something like Iron Man
you look at where the way that's shot
the suit CGI but most of the the sets
and locations they go to are real places
so they're not
spending they don't have to build those
places a lot of the time because they
just go to locations and doing it and
when you start filming everything on
green screen it just skyrockets your
cost and I've started thinking about
that and when they talk about how they
want to do blade for aund million and
people are like well how can they easily
do that for that much money it's
probably because they're going to shoot
on location and just use real costumes
and the vampires will probably just be
normal people walking around with like
fake vampire fangs in and stuff but once
you start doing like an Aquaman thing
where it's all under the
sea you're spending a hell of a lot of
money already just off that concept
alone yeah oh a thousand perc uh when
you go into this terrain of re when
every when you become extremely reliant
on VFX in
particular that will extend on cost for
re-shoot that'll uh extend on now the
cost for extending on a production in
general and they want this ability to
sort of control literally every element
and post
when people like Nolan they plan in
advance and it it's just kind of funny
thinking about how there's this inverse
that has sort of occurred in Hol hwood
where I I feel like growing up when a
movie was like just bombastic with CGI
and visual effects that was the
conversation of just wow look at this
mesmerizing Hollywood film with all the
CGI and every shot as a visual effect
shot now it's impressive when it's a
Nolan film when it's Oppenheimer we're
like there's no visual effect shots in
here at all because there's there has
become a an over Reliance on on CGI in
particular so
I because I think a lot of the time they
don't really know what it is they want
to do with certain things like the
production for the first Aquaman was
batshit that was insane and they had
drastically changed the look um
immensely by the time we actually saw
the film and I haven't seen the lost
kingdom I've heard there's some good CGI
then I've heard there's some really bad
CGI in in the film as well which is
baffling uh because You' think that they
would kind of have an avatar effect
where they would one up their game and
go all right well the first one was
known for being like look how cool this
world is now let's even go crazier and
look even better but I've heard a lot of
people kind of dog on the CGI for that
film it's okay yeah i' would say it's
it's it's standard Affair for these kind
of movies where it's yeah I would say
it's better than Quantum Mania um it
doesn't look all look like it's shot on
a green screen like Quantum Mania did
where they were just standing and you'd
have like something off in the back it's
kind of a a fluid World excuse the fun
that's better I mean I I think too that
I heard that they set out to have fun
and and I feel like you know what you're
talking about with the fun quality of
things if you look at some of these
movies that we were just mentioning
alone there's so much fun to be had in
them Guardians 3 I remember there's a
lot of laughter that the theater was
having with that film maybe not in
Britain because apparently you guys
don't OT but out here people were having
a great time and in uh Whatchamacallit
uh Spider-Man into the across the
spiderverse that's yeah that one people
were having a ball during it so there
there is a lot of fun but there's also a
lot of dramatic heft as well and I think
when it came to Guardians people just
kind of took the wrong lessons it's kind
of the same way when Batman Begins came
out and people will take wrong lessons
from things
ofing yeah yeah they're very much
influenced and I think too that's what
happens with that's how cinematic
universes came to be and they're like oh
fun let's make everything jokey but
you're like no no that's not that's not
just it even the first Guardians movie
which is a lot of fun knew when to have
that emotional weight it's kind of like
with Thor Ragnarok to love of Thunder
you know they take the wrong Tao they
seem to have taken the wrong lessons
from what worked with uh the last one
and maybe Marvel I imagine too over
looking love and thunder took the wrong
lessons of what worked with Ragnarok and
went okay just magnify this but let's
exclude this other stuff as much so yeah
I think in
general they have to reexamine
everything well come take a journey with
me through time Greg and the listeners
let's look back at like older movies and
think about them and genuinely we'll see
right I'm going to I've just thought
about it here you will see when a
serious franchise turns to Comedy it
destroys the
franchise Superman you know the Richard
Donna thing yeah it was light-hearted
but it it took itself seriously jump to
like Superman 3 when it's slapstick like
a 10 minute slapstick scene at the start
of the film and then Superman 4 destroys
the franchise Batman 89 Greg starts off
really serious Batman Returns very
serious Batman Forever bit serious but
sort of bit jokey Batman and Robin
bloody hell went all out joke kill the
franchise um and the dceu another
example of that you know that town that
was set in Man of Steel
really serious took itself serious um
and yeah I know a lot of people don't
enjoy that take of Superman I personally
really do um but we've slowly seen over
time that it's got more and more wackier
and and that's the same thing that's
happened with the MCU if you look at um
Iron Man The Incredible Hulk Captain
America Thor I know I got there sort us
wrong it it's it started off quite
serious but it had jokes in but now it's
getting more and more leaning towards
comedy for example She-Hulk um Thor love
and thunder that sort of thing and it's
kind of yeah it feels like the wheels
start to fall off when they do that and
just thinking about I can't think of a
franchise off the top of my head that's
started off serious and then has leaned
more towards comedy that's managed to
keep going and it hasn't destroyed
itself once it's hit that point maybe
Deadpool but that was always a comedy
thing you know what I mean I think tonal
shifts in general might not work within
franchises because we fall in love with
those first couple of films and then to
see the franchise steer in a different
direction it's kind of I don't know and
I do kind of feel that's almost why Star
Wars has remained so successful because
I know people hate on the newest stuff
but tonally it at least feels in line
with you know the Mandalore for example
the Mandalorian season one are I got
that on 4K the other day and I rewatched
it and I'm thinking tonally this is
completely in line with what's came
before and it
works well Thor the first one while
there's humor in it another there's some
there's jokes to be had it sold itself
especially in the marketing as a pretty
serious film and then the the Ragnarok
became way more comedic and that was uh
true true that's like one one example
that I could think of I can't thanks for
dismantling my entire Point thought I
was really on something there going back
through time there's only one but no I
mean I I think there has the humor humor
and fun of things just has to come from
within the characters if you look at
Zack Snider's Justice League and then
the Weeden cut of Justice League there's
humor in Zack Snider's Justice League
but it's coming from certain characters
you know uh certain moments from flash
like that whole thing when Superman uh
comes back to life that was a a really
funny moment and you know when flash is
like looking at running after him and
he's like scared there's there's actual
comedy there's there's actual humorous
moments there or when flash interacts
with Batman in the Batcave oh no no no
flip that he interacts with Bruce Wayne
and his little Barry Allen cave that
he's got going on so there is humor and
that's coming from Barry Allen the
character himself but you know when you
look at the Weeden cut even in the scene
where Superman's resurrected there's
more jokes added in here there's the
lasso scene there's other things that
take that make the movie feel goofy now
um you know there's the scene where
there's a lot of like weed and cut jokes
that are have not have not uh gestated
well over time and so I think that's the
missing ingredients like people often
look at just make it funny but the funny
has to seem natural characters yeah yeah
it has to like Infinity War has jokes
you know
there's a plenty of jokes in there but
they're coming from within the
characters themselves and yeah Jes write
jokes that's the problem with it that's
probably the best that's probably most
efficient way to put it characters are
not the are not jokes um yeah yeah and I
do feel kind of I think the the dceu was
just doomed from the start of the year
like one of the dumbest things that they
did was announcing it was the end when
they could have like Greg I've said this
to death as well I feel like this is
just like eclipse of this year episode
where we just repeat all the points but
every time we've talked about a DC EU
movie and it's bombed we've been like
guys there was no need to announce that
none of these movies mattered until 2024
and they could have happily come out
next month and being like you know guys
thanks for all your support with the
dceu we're going in a New Direction and
I really hope gun sees this and
decides oh I need a completely cut ties
with this thing and just reboot it from
the ground up because again I I and I
know you guys always argue with me about
this in the comments I feel like the you
can the writing's on the wall at this
point where we've had so many bombs and
it's just going to pull down Superman
Legacy if this is attached to it in any
way I think Aquaman failing is one of
the best things that could have happened
for this reboot in the weirdest way I
have a my my tin foil hat comes on that
they really wanted this one to fail uh
because of imagine if it was a great
film imagine if people loved it people
would be like oh why are they
discontinuing the
dceu but when you've had like flop after
flop and and then I and then they barely
promoted this one it seems like they
really did not want this one to swim
above Shores they wanted this one to
sink into the depths of the Atlantis
ocean because now there's [__] people I
think people will be way more receptive
now to a reboot it's it's just the way
things go something shitty will go all
right over for a reboot now the SNY cuts
the perfect example of that you had um a
universe that was going in a certain way
and a hell of a lot of fans who were
saying no it needs to go back to what it
was with Zack Snider's vision and we
need and even like after the Snider cut
released restore the SN verse was
trending all the time and now you I
think you probably are right and it's a
good thing overall that it's done badly
and hasn't been well received like I
actually quite like the film Greg I
tweeted it out and the Embargo hadn't
lifted yet and it was uh I realized
that yeah the I just I've never
experienced that before where I've went
to see something the actual day of
release and I went in to tweet my
thoughts I tweeted it and then I
realized oh the the Embargo hasn't even
lifted yet so I quickly deleted the
Tweet they W the Warner Brothers after
me Greg um but I I said I thought it was
okay and it was one of those moments
where I'm sure you've had it before
where you'll either say something's
amazing or you'll say it's really bad
and you'll be a voice you know like that
Meme where everyone's sat down and
there's the one person standing up H I
felt like that at that moment because I
was like the only one saying thought it
was okay guys didn't think it was
horrendous as everyone's saying um but
yeah I mean I what I should have done is
write that really positive thing delete
it and then wait to see what everyone
else said and then change my review to
fit in with that oh yeah but yeah that
was a bit of a strange day um and
obviously there are other factors you
know Amber Her had a hell of a lot of
headlines the last couple of years that
petition with millions of signatures on
um and I sort of saw this film almost
like the boys Comics right the when
superheroes when they in injected with v
compound V and they get killed their
brain kind of refres like reanimate
because of the compound V searching
through their system right now V can't
be like oh we've been injecting people
with compound V so what they do is they
have a little Fair well toour where they
bring that hero out they're completely
brain dead going like mumbling along and
they say oh this hero we're doing a good
goodbye to her and just kind of prop
them up and then say look they're going
off to Mars and they're going to go live
in Mars and fight the aliens over on
that side and that's kind of what this
felt like it was like a farewell tour of
the DCU but they're they're off in the
George Clooney Universe with Ezra
Miller's career and Amber hood and Jason
mamora they're all over that way just
enjoying it and we give you we give you
guys the farewell to her yeah and I
think you are right I think had this
been good you know fans might have been
online demanding that that Universe
continue whereas it's been so killed off
that it's uh it's it's dead now and you
know we'll see what James gun does he's
obviously said that Blue Beetle is the
first DCU hero but so they might try and
connect it in with that I would just say
just just cut it off mate it's like it's
like the end of saw you know you want to
get you trapped you're trapped with that
handcuff around you you want to get out
of it just saw it off and get out of
there just cut it off and we'd love to
take the foot with us we'd love to but
we can't it's going bad just cut it off
and go please just go just go I agree
let it go I think I mean sholo he's he's
a really Charming actor I like blue beo
quite a bit uh yeah there is a there's a
way sometimes these things happen
sometimes these things happen they call
it Kill Your Darlings kill your babies
is one of the creative choices they say
and yeah I would love for Ben Affleck to
keep coming back as Batman you know what
I mean I would love for that to happen
and he wants it to obviously yeah sholo
blue beat I enjoyed it but unfortunately
it dropped in this weird time period
where that was another film that they
could have easily have delayed for a
couple of years um and unfortunately uh
just please just cut it
off that why didn't they just delay
it like that is a very I mean it might
have made some weird headlines of oh
maybe they have a lack of faith in or
something but I I feel like they could
if if it was really the new DCU
character why put that in
between
another dce it just makes it uh it's
mind it's a mindboggling choice you
could have just delayed the film it
doesn't affect the Shazam timeline or
the Aquaman or the flash timeline just
delay it and then your vision for
whatever it is you are placing forward
will be clear to your audience it's kind
of yeah seems like common sense to me
it's logical isn't
it yeah and know guys we're not really
having a structured conversation here
we're just kind of going off on other
tangents about DC in general but I was
thinking the other day right about the
SN cut um because Rebel moons came out
obviously and that's got me itching to
go back and rewatch The SN cut um but I
was thinking at the end way T car was
meant to be the Green Lantern in that
but Warner Brothers put an aand out and
said look we're using we're using Green
Lantern in the future and we don't want
people getting confused with it so
you're going to have to cut him out of
it and I was thinking they could have
easily have just put him in and
not everything would have been fine
because they're they're resetting the
whole thing but uh
yeah sorry I know we keep trying to move
on that's that's another like at that
point War Bird should have been like
well you can't use Batman because we got
like three other Batman we're using
right now so it's so you're gonna
confuse our audience if you use Batman
in this movie so yeah they could have us
dump in whoever yeah I mean you had dark
side at the end of it yeah just dump in
whoever just get everyone on board who
cares if you're just in it anyway let
yeah sure put green lanter in it get
whoever you want yeah that takes us over
to Rebel Moon um which the viewership
it's difficult to report on this stuff
because there's so many voices on
Twitter right now that are saying one
thing and the next people will say a
completely different thing so Rebel moon
this is from what's on Netflix and if
you you guys want to correct me that's
totally fine but it says Rebel Moon
debuts after 4 days with
23.9 million views in comparison murder
mystery 2 that Adam Sandler film I think
I got 42.9 million the mother got 42.9
million and Leave the World Behind got
4117 million that gonut film from
earlier in the air Greg Heart of Stone
you remember it every of course everyone
remembers that that was great the title
man that got 33.1 million so yeah it got
pretty much more than 10 million views
than Rebel Moon and yeah what why do you
think that is Greg what do you think is
going on with Rebel moon what did you
think of it in
general I thought it was fine uh I
didn't love it I really didn't love it
and I'll be honest with you I think the
the most disappointing part of it to me
is it
didn't it didn't get me unlike Batman v
Superman and unlike even the weed and
cutter Justice League it didn't
particularly get me super interested in
the director's cut the only thing that's
getting me interested in the director's
Cut Is the way they're pitching it as
like this totally different film and
Vibe and everything so I'm G to watch it
like regardless even if my initial
interest right now isn't exactly super
high the it's because I I didn't give a
[__] about like any of the characters
and I in the first half hour and 40
minutes of it I was I was thinking
thinking to actually before uh Sophia
batella left farm land tattooing spot
was that you know this movie is like
yeah it's full of tropes and whatever
but I'm enjoying it it's fine and then
after she left I was like you know I
could really use some interesting
characters here and then the as as it
just kept progressing I I found my
interest in it going down it was like so
fluctua between this looks really cool
too but but I keep losing interest in
the they just show up recruit someone
and sometime and I just don't really
care and I kind of forget what the main
plot is even though the plot is so
simple it's it's the Magnificent Seven
plot it's the Seven Samurai plot you
know recruit to save and yet I would I
feel like the movie would lose sight of
its simple premise so I I think it was a
fine it was fine but it it was
I what I would definitely wasn't in love
with it and and I think the conversation
around it didn't help bolster its its
numbers it wasn't thought-provoking and
if you don't love Zack Snyder I don't
think you're gonna like like I I really
I really don't think this is going to
win over anyone whereas like Leave the
World Behind as as much as some people
like seemed to totally [__] on the
ending like that was if you if you look
at the reviews for that movie
like good critic score the audience
score is is wow they're really ripping
it apart but man it creates a
conversation though the movie creates
conversation uh regardless of what you
think if you think it's pretentious or
whatever uh it still creates
conversation and or is this call like a
million views making leave behind videos
just talking about what I thought was in
it and it's like yeah everyone was like
I don't know if I like this movie I
don't know where the hell is this is
rubbish what's going on it's yeah it's
kind of that Netflix thing that captures
the moment almost like Bird Box did
where it's very sort of yeah it just
captures everyone's interest they always
release it around December time and it
kind of people watch it as a and it's
got good word of mouth basically and I
don't think Rebel Moon had that at all
it was obviously it was pitched as a
Star Wars script and it it's kind of
crazy how similar it is to Star Wars as
well you got a character on the farm
wanted to go out um meeting Rogues and
Rebels along the way but it does I don't
think it has that camaraderie amongst
them you know like yeah Suicide Squad is
a really crappy movie that's kind of
hatcheted together but they have that
scene when they're in the bar and they
all kind of bond and there's not that
one scene in Rebel Moon where they're
all kind of just sitting around and
telling their stories and bonding and
you know getting to know each other so I
don't get to know the characters and I
don't feel like they're a group that's
why I I'm not super because I I guess I
didn't really get an inkling of
chemistry amongst the cast
so when I think about the Extended Cut
I'm not that interested in it because of
that I'm like sure well the it's not
really the world that's the problem for
me it it is is like so much of that
movie could have been saved simp simply
by scene workor simply by actors
interacting with each other and having
like really good real good chemistry and
like every actor who they cast is is a
good actor that that's the thing like
everyone who's cast is a good actor it's
it's just like you show up they give a
monologue or someone gives exposition to
them they do something unless you're
jaman hansu who just shows up to give a
monologue and they just on the team I I
think that was like when the whole thing
with Ray Fischer's
character I don't know I just didn't
give a [__] I I just really didn't give
a [__] I like Ed screen uh I thought he
was a fun villain I thought he was a
really fun villain um and the part two
trailer I'm going to give it a shot uh
but yeah I wasn't I and and you know I
think some people I I hear a lot of
people off um talk about how they
thought the visuals
fluctuated I like the visuals a lot uh I
I think it was actually one of Zack
Snider's best looking films and maybe
that's not a popular opinion I I really
thought the visuals were Rock Solid I
think a lot of time it's just with Zack
Snyder he's not look I I like to love
most of his films like bottom line I do
uh we said it last time the only one you
haven't seen is the owl one and I
haven't seen Sucker Punch and I I think
though what he usually needs is a good
WR like he needs a good screenwriter
there to help flesh out his vision you
know like he's a he he at the end of the
day he's he's a kind of artistic
director who comes from aesthetic and
mood and and there's nothing wrong with
his approach but that's why he's a
director and you need a good
screenwriter to help fill in all that
other stuff you know and he's even known
as being a Visionary you know it's from
Visionary director Zack Snider whenever
his name's presented in a trailer or
something it's always kind of with that
and I do I I Snider I really do like his
work and I know I get [__] on for that
but I think for me it's always this
extended cuts that I really think those
are the good ones like
Watchmen um obviously the SNY car even
Batman v Superman it's the Extended Cut
and hearing that one's coming I do feel
like oh well this has a chance of Rec
ifying all my problems that I have with
the film but yeah I feel the same as you
I was kind of let down by I think even
beyond the Star Wars comparisons I'm not
a big Warhammer fan but I know lots of
people saying it's pretty much just
Warhammer but even things like the the
guy going to The Village at the start
it's very similar to Inglorious Bastards
it's a very derivative movie yeah it's
very derivative like they go to a
Cantina and they have that scene that
Luc and noi Wan had with the guy but
this time it's like weird
guy wanting sex with the Gunner guy and
yeah it's just kind of it's it just
feels like stuff that you've seen before
and it
wasn't as you know enthralling as I
really hoped it would be so that and I
know the word of mouth hasn't been that
good on it I think that Netflix were
kind of banking on a fan movement which
is why they held back the extended cuts
and it at the moment that there just
hasn't been that yet and I think they've
kind of shut themselves in the foot
starting a new universe this way where
it's going to be like we've released the
even like even Zach's out there saying
that his extended cut the better version
of the film that's the one he wanted to
make and stuff and it's just like why
have you done this um and movie studios
in general Greg they're just all over
the place so we're going to jump into
the next topic which is movie studios
grading and it's come from variety what
they've done is they've taken the highs
of low of each studio and graded them
this year and uh we'll see if we
disagree we'll see if we agree I I
haven't seen I haven't seen any of this
yet this is my first time I you sent me
this so let's goes this is a reaction
live reaction exclusive exclusive so
Disney yeah our well it's been a very
bad year for Disney and the first
sentence is oh how the mighty have
fallen um and then they they start
backpedaling at this point saying well
relatively speaking of course Disney is
still a leader in terms of market share
however they noted that James Cameron's
Avatar the way of water released at the
end of 2022 grossed more in 2023 than
most of the studios would be
Blockbusters oh wow so yeah they they've
basically brought up a year that we
often talk about with Disney which is
2019 and which I think pretty much all
of their movies grossed a billion and it
was a massive thing um and it's they've
started to show the cracks recently so
they've graded their M C+ Greg and
they've said the highs are Guardians of
the Galaxy volume 3 the Little Mermaid
and Elemental the latter of two we
slagged off on the podcast Greg we were
saying they did badly but I think
Elemental especially had legs and just
kept growing and growing still haven't
seen The Little Mermaid so I'm not sure
about that but they said the Lowe's were
the Marvels um which was obviously a big
bomb and it kind of was bad for just
comic book movies in general I think
when the Marvel's bombed it was almost a
sign of like oh crap is this the end you
know when a DC movie bombs it's like
like oh yeah whatever M DC movies rarely
do well when a Marvel MCU movie bombs
it's like oh crap is that what's
happening and then Indiana Jones in the
dial of destiny that was that they're
reporting H so that made 383 million the
Marvels made 204 million and wish was a
big uh underperformer with 126 million
so yeah the Marvel's only grossing that
is absolutely insane to me I remember
when we were talking about kind of box
office predictions um me and good friend
of the podcast best friend in the whole
world Greg if you we're always having a
laughing that me and the guys Brandon
Davis went on his podcast better friend
than I with him than I'll ever be with
you you son of a [__] and but yeah we
were both saying we we think the Marvels
will do half a billion and Greg we were
get absolutely slated in the comments
and for it to do even worse than that to
do half of that pretty much it's very
bad it's very bad even my lowest
expectations Greg if it had have made my
lowest expectations they probably would
have been happy but man this is crazy
that's what happens so how you feeling
about Disney this year
Greg how do I feel about Disney this is
not even including Disney plus [__] it's
just movies right this is just movies oh
wow that is a we've talked extensively
about so much of
this you
know okay none of this is is really a
surprise to me of what we're seeing here
the one that is just popping out to me
is wish because Disney and I know it's
not the like the the hot one to talk
about like we we rag on all these other
ones or whatever and yeah I agree with
this rating sure it's is is like what
growing up man growing
up what did you think about with Disney
you thought about their animated movies
that's what you thought about now you
hear Disney I don't even think about
about animated movies with Disney I
think about this [__] right here you
know like I don't I don't I don't ever
think about like their their handdrawn
or even their computer animated stuff
you I even really even Pixar you know
like they just see Elemental on those
list like oh yeah that's a Pixar movie
they did and wish was supposed to be
touted as like their 100 years or
whatever and yeah return to full that is
the most disheartening aspect of this is
how much it's lost sight of what has
made Disney so special like have they
had other liveaction things along the
way uh even in the Journey of Growing Up
on Disney and loving them and being
known for their animated stuff yeah
absolutely that's what made them the
most special and again wish is another
one I haven't seen the uh I think yeah
this list of highs and lows wish is the
only one I haven't seen and to me that
is the saddest one of them all it's the
lowest grossing one but to me it's the
most disheartening one because you know
like Indiana Jones wasn't always Disney
that really hurts me Greg I really
wanted a good Indiana Jones movie oh
yeah and when I heard you know James
mangle doing it Harrison Ford was like
crying in interviews and stuff and
saying like he was so happy he' be back
and then to just see him at the end of
the movie kind of blobbing away and then
get punched and knocked out by a girl
and taken back home it's kind of like
wow you really could have had the guy go
out in a blaze of glory on top showing
everyone and you've reduced them to like
a pathetic man who's just been knocked
out and taken home for and put to bed
it's strange out of all the ones on the
list yeah I would say Indiana Jones is
the most disappointing one I haven't
seen wish but uh that I was I was
surprised because I I like the first
like half hour the Legacy Indiana Jones
carries as well I mean that's what was
the most disappointing for me um
I think out of all the
sequels this is obviously going to be
have the longest Legacy to it because
the franchise is so fast whereas like I
don't think there's another movie on
this list that it's the first movie was
like that long ago you know what I mean
um so they gave it a C+ I'm I'm not
scoring it a C+ I would be like a d just
for how you hand well maybe even lower
maybe an e because I've just re
remembered about how they handled the
strike and pretty much all the
conversation around Disney is how bad
they're doing and quantam Mania is not
on here yeah I mean Quantum Mania did
okay um I wouldn't say it was a high I
wouldn't say it was a low either I think
it I think it did okay okay I mean
didn't gross as much as Ant-Man and the
WASP I don't think but it was
still it I think it just made a profit
and I might be wrong on that and might
have lost money but it wasn't like a
colossal loss you know what I mean it
wasn't one of the biggest box off off
bombs of all time for example like the
Marvels or Indiana Jones's so I'm going
to I was going to say a d but for how
they handled the strike and just Bob
Iger talking [__] I'm gonna drop it I'm
gonna drop it down to an F actually for
Bob Iger and and that's because right if
that guy had just left when he left and
he quit he would have been known as the
greatest CEO of all time he would have
been like well Bob AR was when he was
running Disney they were just getting
home run billion dollar every single
film home run um and Bob Chek you know
he I think Bob Chek probably did better
than what the run that Bob AGA 2.0's had
and I think you know if Chek had to kept
running it we would have just been like
this never would have happened under Bob
AER he was the best he's the greatest so
I'm dropping it down to an F just for
the strikes how how many movies have
bombed and Bloody Bob AER just con
ruining his legacy ruined it he could
have been the greatest SE of all time
Bob and you ruined
it I agree man I agree what's the next
one you going with an f as well I would
go oh for a letter uh for
Disney yeah I I mean I guess I'll meet
you at a d might D for Disney we'll go D
for Disney that's a okay way to do it
because yeah they I think I think
they're if we're looking at just from
like the financial side like I I guess
variety know better than than me of for
looking at from just like a pure optic
side from from how like the um the
conversation and emotional association
with Disney is going I would probably
put that lower than a d like they have
really gone downhill in terms of that
like you can have a financial you can
have a year where you're like ah I've
had some low performing videos but once
you've you have tarnished a lot of the
reputation though and that's a complet
like I'm looking at I quickly like did a
quick skim of some of these other movies
and I'm like oh yeah these other studios
are not I mean Warner Brothers is a
conversation to be had but it's not the
same as Disney you know um yeah I would
say Warner Brothers and Disney those two
have kind of their CEOs especially kind
of ruined the reputation of those
Studios whereas like Paramount I don't
hear people talking [__] about the the
CEO of Paramount you know what I mean
even though they've had a couple of like
dingers but yeah no like War Brothers in
Disney have a they have a they have a
face they have a villain
associated with it you know where's the
other ones I'm like I don't know who
runs these other Studios actually I'm
not familiar you know but those two yeah
you guys just enjoy being billionaires
and keeping yourselves to yourselves
very smart so that takes us into
Paramount their Highs are Scream Six Paw
Patrol teenage M teenage mut I don't
know why I said teenage might teenage
mutant ninja turtles mutant Mayhem and
killers of the flower Moon they're lows
Greg and I'm annoyed at these lows
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one and Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves hell mate dungeons that were
both like Mission Impossible you didn't
like that but was good no you didn't
like Dungeons and Dragons my God they're
both terrible fil I'm just joking
man dragons especially though is a great
film how's that a low I I would put that
above all the ones in the highs and it
made more money than those ones as well
so yeah Dungeons and Dragons right made
208 million Scream 6 made 169 Paw Patrol
197 Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 180 and
killers of the flower Moon 156 so the
Lowe's Dungeons and Dragons made more
money than all those and it was a bloody
good movie as well why is that in the
low section variety what the this is
this is classic clickbait markting rage
bait you driving me to share this
article everywhere because I'm so angry
um so they gave them a B
minus I feel like that I would go a
b more to make than Dungeons and Dragons
am I wrong about that yeah yeah that's I
think it did but I mean I don't know how
they how much they sold it to Apple for
they probably made a crap out right it's
an apple
thing um yeah and obviously they would
have agreed with how much money Apple
were going to pay them before they
released it um so yeah I I think
Paramount's had a pretty strong year um
I I there's not a movie out of them I
haven't seen Paw Patrol but there's not
a movie there that I don't think is good
good to great um box office returns
aren't amazing but yeah solid solid year
by them I'm gonna go with a B I don't
know man I think I would go with a B B
minus I think I would stick with it
because dead reckoning part one
especially uh is a big dent like the
after top gun Maverick being a bill I
know different franchises different at
the end of the day it's like you're GNA
get a more of an audience for top gun
Maverick because of that
Nostalgia and but the last mission
imposta movie was a huge film and I we
know all the factors of all the things
of why dead reckoning part one was
affected at the box office but it is a
dip it is a it is a big hit I think
honestly like dead reckoning part and
they wanted Dungeons and Dragons to kind
of SAR them into I don't know like a
like a pirates of the Caribbean
franchise or something like that they
wanted it to sort of go into that
direction
so it's only the first movie to be fair
I think it will it I think it'll be like
an into the spiders situation where you
know people weren't necessarily into it
when it first released and then it gets
good word of mouth people enjoy it and
if they made a sequel I'd be their day
one I think a lot of people who missed
out the first time I think they'll show
up for it I think you're starting off a
new franchise don't expect every single
film to be a million dollar kickart you
know what I mean um and that takes us
into Sony Sony have actually not had a
bad year so like Sony are normally the
people who show up go play football with
you trip over the ball smack themselves
in the face get a concussion and have to
go home but Sony year they've had a much
better year than Disney have um so the
highs were Spider-man across the
spiderverse brilliant film one of the
best films of the Year equalizer 3 yeah
another another good one Napoleon
haven't seen it the lows dumb money and
65 and I will agree with that 65
especially when I heard Adam
Driver La crash landing on Earth 65
million years ago and fighting dinosaurs
with guns I was thinking T Rock I was
thinking this is going to be the best
movie ever I was thinking this is going
to gross billions because Jurassic World
movies they're absolutely terrible and
they make billion dollars I think
dinosaurs is just a way to print money
and this proved me wrong so uh yeah bad
you know bad that was but uh yeah across
the spiderverse I think probably the
best comic book movie of the year I
would say got it yeah okay I'm starting
to understand this list because it's
conf it's a little confused you got to
like read some of it a little bit right
because I like wait a minute why is
Napoleon a high when I I thought this
budget was $200 million but okay
yeah distributor for cost 690 million to
make across the spider V Greg I know but
I'm saying that like why would Napoleon
be considered a high when I'm like it
didn't make it it barely broke even
right like has it even broke it even but
it's a success because Apple financed it
and they were only the distributor for
hire so they made and that's kind of uh
I think that's what Killers with the
flower Moon situation was so they were
able to make a a good chunk of change
off of that so I it's like did Apple is
Apple going to make money off of it um
but no that makes that makes sense man
yeah I think I think B I think it go
little I it be like a B+ for freaking
Sony I was gonna go B+ yeah this is this
is a great year for them man it's a
great year because they have PlayStation
as well they have their PlayStation yes
but they have the but they have these
two movie like equalizer 3 and across
the spiderverse were also well-received
films I like for me I know we're only
looking at box office and financial gain
stuff on this I am factoring in
reputation we'll see how things go when
they release like Madam Webb and Craven
the Hunter and vom 3 all in one year
but yeah they're releasing all that this
year aren't they oh my God it's all it's
all they're gonna drop all that
[__] I'm going to give it a B+ but I
might Edge it to an a just because they
released that Spider-Man game this year
as well so I enjoy that but we're
sticking with movies I'm not doing
Technic I know I did CEOs to drag down
Disney but we just keep it with movies
from now on but if I was scoring it on
the studio releasing
Spider-Man PlayStation 5 part two
whatever I would give it an A but it's
getting a B+ but Universal right much as
I hate them much as they block my videos
all the timeing or a nightmare to deal
with they've had probably the best year
out of all these guys so the highs were
the Super Mario Brothers movie which did
1.36 billion Oppenheimer which did 951
million I feel like it's going to cross
the billion mark because they're
re-releasing it um I think it probably
will Edge it I think you know they'll be
that the they they like the C files
Nolan's got the C files in the palm of
his little hand and that they'll show up
I'll probably buy tickets just to try
and push it over that um and they had
Five Nights at Freddy's which did really
well and Megan which did really well
lows right they've got fast X in the
lows but I didn't even realize this fast
X made 74 million yeah like you that's
quite a lot especially with the way this
year has been I think a lot of movies
this year would have been very very
happy to make 704
million like two billion dollar to put
together man it was an expensive movie
true true B Club not heard of that
apparently that was a low Renfield field
was all right what are you talking about
the hell's book
club and last Voyage of the Dem yeah
that was pretty disappointing to be
honest I was very excited for that movie
Dracula on a boat basically an alien
remake with Dracula and I was thinking
this is gonna bang um but yeah not a
good film but overall I agree with that
Universal score I might I would say an a
yeah two yeah two of the biggest movies
of the year the Super Mario brothers and
Oppenheimer and they also pulled Nolan
out from under Warner Brothers as well
and got them working for them so much as
I hate you
Universal much as you make my life a
nightmare you've done all right what are
your thoughts on universal Greg I think
you're I'd eded a tidy bit clo like it's
it's what if there was a a letter grade
between a to a plus I would go there
because they they they had just an in a
phenomenal year I forgot was the kickoff
of this year the these are phenomenons
these movies these these four movies at
the top they're they're they are massive
films like um all pierce the zeist you
know what I mean like these they were
all conversations even like Super Mario
Brothers was the legs on that film Five
Nights at Freddy's too to have a day and
date release uh with peacock where you
can watch this [__] on the streaming
service and it still was a massive hit
it's not to mention the profit that they
made off these movies you know of what
because I I forget that like Universal
and Blum House are the same yeah I would
give them a little bit
Grade B up inimer um those movies are
going to have strong sequels as well I
feel they're all in production at the
moment Super Mario Brothers 2 is
obviously going to come Megan 2's going
to come we're definitely going to get
Megan 3 with the three in e which they
already kind of did um but Five Nights
at Freddy's as well that's already in
production so yeah theyve had a really
strong Year got legs going into the
future probably going to have another
strong year once those things
release they'll do another movie with
Nolan I'm guessing um and that'll be a
big hit as well I've given it an eight
Greg i'm G to pull it down to a z
because of all the copyright strikes
that they send me they get no they get
nothing from me biggest asshol I'm the
teacher in the class and the universal
stuck a whoopy cushion on my my seat and
it had a pin in it and I know it was
them and I don't care what they put out
don't care what they answer the test
it's a z it's the lowest you can get
universally your SC bags they are such
an anxiety
for
my they'll literally like block some of
my videos months after they've been
released and I'm I'm like I don't even
know if I should dispute this cuz I've
already made probably all the money that
I'm going to make but I just don't like
having that strike on the channel and I
know they're going to lift it eventually
but when they reject the dispute and
then you've got to go through the next
thing and it's
like just makes it doesn't make the job
fun guys and it's this movies it's just
talking about
movies see a Warner Brothers is the next
Studio they've been given a B+ right I
don't feel
like I think tank in the DC euu is is
kind of automatically you get a d for
that
uh I guess it it averages out from you
know the like okay if the DCU tanking
brings it to an F but then you know
Barbie just like helps take that ship
out of the water acting as an Aquaman if
you will taking it out of the water then
yeah I I would put it maybe at like a b
perhaps [__] off you know because come
on man I mean Wonka's doing great and
Meg 2 made 300 that's got to be like
International holy crap that's a lot of
money that's so so the highs we we'll
talk about the article so the highs for
Warner Brothers are Barbie with 1.44
billion obviously very very good the nun
two did it do well 268 million I suppose
it that was horror movies cost nothing
to make Meg twos are
high and Wonka yeah Wonka is doing well
280 million today Lowe's The Flash geez
Blue Beetle obviously didn't do well
Shazam 2o forgot it had released burned
that on my head I bought the 4K
steelbook for that for like 35 quid to
just have it in my collection still
ain't bloody watched it just sat on the
Shelf NE rarely do that I'll just buy it
put it on that's still on the Shelf
there since it's released and see
Aquaman and the lost they've even put
Aquaman in the lost city here it's
Aquaman and the lost kingdom vary you
don't even care that
much I think no I think before when we
were talking about all the headlines
that the Marvels get that are like
really bad the fact that we don't even
have the those headlines for Aquaman
shows how little people care like no one
even cares enough to dunk on it it's
kind of like just kicking kicking
something when they're down I didn't
even notice so they've got a B they've
got a B+ according to variety I disagree
I would I think the way they they pretty
much tanked the comic book movie
industry with just releasing bad film
like bad performing films um obviously
they not lost Nolan as well zaslav Jesus
I don't know what the hell he's been
doing you had all the controversy with
them canceling
bgirl I would say I'm giving them and E
Greg I I just think War suppose they had
the last of us we push it up because
they had the last of us well we can't
you keep you keep giving it other things
that aren't on this list uh the I think
it's they I'm just teacher I just like
my
students it seems like they would have
like a flop hit flop hit flop hit so I I
think like a b or a C+ is more fair uh
than a b do you not think the amount of
money they lost on those I mean those
superhero Aquaman one made a billion
dollars Greg do you see how do you
mishandle it that badly to the point you
don't even have a red car premere no one
goes to see it that is
bad I have no it's like did you in high
school in America do you guys have like
before your final exams is the year
before kind of like you have a a sort of
fake exam at the end of it that's kind
of getting you prepared for that CU in
England when was aad I realized the
other day it's been 20 years since I
took my final exams at school so I'm
getting quite old Dam
but so we have like year year 10 and
year 11 year 11's where you get like
your your final exams year 10's sort of
like you doing mocks and stuff you're
building up to it they had they got a a
billion they got all top marks in the
the air 10 year 11 they showed up to the
exams they dropped the ball and
everything they [__] it and I'm
marking them down Greg I'm I'm I like
them they had potential there was a time
I I was out there every day going I love
DC movies I love them so much and now
it's like I love Matt Reeves and Todd
Phillips DC movies and everything else
is kind of fine but if they ended it I'd
be absolutely fine with it damn they
they really
lost all their DC movies did were were
flops that's kind of just hitting me
right now it's like I knew yeah but I
didn't really feel it till right now
every film was a bum damn every single
one of them and it just how can you give
them a b because of
Barbie yeah man I mean Barbie is the
biggest movie of the year you got to
give it points man Barbie's the biggest
movie of the year and it's also got like
nomin but if a student scores the lowest
marks on every single exam except one
and you're like oh well
this a big Mark man it's a great extra
credit point to me man like bar me and
nun two cost like 30 million to make I'm
assuming and and and Wonka is doing
great yeah but no one cares about nun
two it that was just something teenagers
probably went out to see that weekend
because it was nothing else out and it's
like oh I just want to have a jump scare
I just want to watch a movie that's
nothing but jump scares for two for 0
minutes don't care what it is just put
it on I'm not going to concede I'm not
gonna I'm I'm G to settle out a b I'm B
for Barbie I I'll give you a C+ I'm
gonna give a C+ that's that's wrong
right and the
next the next point is Apple which I
don't get how this is in here because it
says highs and lows killers of the
flower Moon and Napoleon how can
Napoleon be in Paramount Apple you know
what I mean how can it be a
high Paramount but it's a low in apple I
think they they basically cut I think
they work together on that for the
financing of it but they're getting a b
as
well I'm going to score them I'm G to
score them a b right I'm gonna give
Apple a b I'll tell you why Greg I feel
a bit bad for them because they do make
good shows and they do make good films
but no one really watches them soon as
that three Monon trial that you get when
you buy a new iPhone ends and it's like
you get three months of Apple TV soon as
that trial ends no no one goes back to
Apple yeah yeah I'm there I'm one of the
I'm part of the problem I don't watch I
I the only Apple show I've seen is
monarch and that's because I have to
cover it I don't I have yeah I haven't
seen Ted lasso too late quit now I don't
even know about the
uh is these are the only movies they
they've made other movies right but
these the only theatrically released
ones they've made
yeah I think that's what they're
counting
yeah that's too bad the same Cinemas
were basically serving as expensive
Billboards for Apple TV
plus I just think I me they got scorsi
and Ridley Scott on board so I think
they cared about the films they were
making and I think I haven't seen
Napoleon but killers of the flower moon
was good enough for me to be like okay I
I'll see what you do in apple the
biggest problem when you release these
movies in the theaters is you're letting
the audio know when when you're say it's
it's like if Netflix were to go Netflix
original releasing in theaters you know
it's only going to be in the theaters
for like a day and it's GNA be on your
TV in like 72 hours so just freaking
wait for it to come out right and and
and so whenever I see these logos for
like with a streaming service it's gonna
and then they're playing a trailer in
the theaters I'm like well part of me is
going do I really want to come back to
the theater to see this you and and yeah
because like Netflix will do these
limited releases but but they are truly
limited you know they're they're
generally in areas for ciles generally
speaking whereas killers of the flower
moon is is an apple original and they're
they're slapping that on in their
trailers and and they're releasing that
across the globe you know so it has a
bigger chance of like losing money on on
these theater
performances so it's it and no one even
really watches Apple TV too to be kid
with so I this is interesting to see on
the list it is interesting I already saw
the gray for the next movie man and I
don't agree with it I just don't I don't
agree with it it should be higher I'm
just saying it right now spoiler
spoilers for the next
one yeah so lion skate he's John Wick
chapter 4 440 million Hunger Games I'm
not going to read out the whole title
saw X and Jesus Revolution
Lowe's are you there God it's me
Margaret Joy Ride the marsh King's
Daughter so Lionsgate get a B plus um so
yeah Lionsgate they've been
congratulated by variety for keeping
budgets in check as both John Wick
chapter 4 in The Hunger Games They
Carried reasonable $100 million price
tags so yeah all turn a profit you know
haven't seen Hunger Games yet but it's
got It's had legs didn't have a crazy
first weekend but it keeps bringing the
money in every weekend and I think it's
going to do well and obviously it's all
because of Rachel Ziggler because every
I mean if you blame Rachel Ziggler for a
movie failing surely it does well has to
be the person who made it to well um so
yeah I and you know what I feel like
Lionsgate are one of those Studios that
are like The Little Engine That Could
I'm kind of rooting for the guys you
know they're not overblown they don't
come out and call the fans idiots and
say they hate them because they didn't
like the movie and I like the way that
Line's gate do business uh I think the
the IPS they have they're they're very
Grassroots IPS um John Wick is obviously
a great example of that that's redefined
action movies in general I know Hunger
Games is based on books mate but it did
start the whole young adult novelization
craze that when there was like The Maze
Runner and all those movies were getting
made that was all off the back of The
Hunger Games and stuff and yeah I think
that yeah I'm I do like lions gate
they've been given a B+ you know they're
not the first Studio that spring to mind
when I think of movie studios are
probably quite low down the list but I'm
going to agree with the B+ I'm going to
say you know what Lionsgate I'm your
teacher you have you haven't exactly
been putting your hand up for every
question answering all the time but
you've sat at the back of the class
you've kept your head down you've got on
with the work you've came out with a
respectable year I'm giving you a B+ you
pull your socks up next year you know
you release something crazy that could
easily be an a lion gate that could
easily be an a well Paul I'm an a with
Lion's gate I really am because look at
this dude look at this John Wick chapter
4440 million that's an R rated film and
the word of mouth on it was so good and
I loved it it's probably was probably
like one of my top three favorite movies
of the year I haven't made a list yet
but I would I would say it's up there
and like the top three and hunger and
and and I know it's not just about you
know your personal favorite movies but I
think that's a really great success
great success bringing back Borat saw X
as well like these are movies that are
so deep in the franchise you know and
they're doing great numbers here usually
a a a four with an action franchise like
on this ah whatever they kind of dip
after a while and then Hunger Games
you're you're not even bringing back the
original cast it's a you have to sell
them on a new cast and the word of mouth
on it with audiences is doing so good
that it's managed to make this much
money I feel like Lionsgate is at an a
with their hits because when I think
about these movies that are lows they're
not on the losses like yes I I like joy
ride a lot I don't know if you've seen
that is a really funny movie uh but and
then I think it was only like a 20 to
$30 million movie so did it lose money
absolutely but the losses to at least
from my understanding are not as Grand
of a scale as especially compared to
what they have made on the films they've
done that continue to make money every
time like the amount of times I see like
sawx or John Wick 4 um doing well on
Prime video on the top 10 video on
demand rentals like I'll just see them
pop up
there they continue to still make money
and sure if we're looking at just box
office where capped off at I still think
it's really great numbers uh personally
for what they were made for and what
they had to sell their audiences on as
well maybe Hunger Games could have been
a little bigger actually is it still out
in theaters I think it is yeah I think
it is I think it's winding down but it's
it's still done pretty well um yeah I
think linescape for me you know that
they're at a B level I think just they
don't quite have that star power to take
them to that next a level you know what
I mean it's not like
a Warner Brothers or Disney level Studio
that in my mind when I think about them
being like that level and I know those
we've been slagging off those two
Studios but when I think of movie
studios those are the ones then
Universal and Paramount and then I think
if they just hit it to that next level
took it to that next tier where they're
in with the big guys
properly I i' give them an a Greg I've
been nice here but I think there's some
stuff they can improve on I think once
you get that a Greg you kind of at the
top and you're at the Pinnacle you you
haven't had that billion this year you
know what I mean Greg so I ain't I ain't
giving you that ay the B+ be a you
better be
thankful doesn't need be a billion
dollars why is it a24 on here is there
something I'm missing yeah why I don't
know where the hell is a24 well a24
getting a every year I don't care what
happens I'm just like yeah you may talk
to me this year boom yeah instant a
instant a didn't Lionsgate do
Expendables that would bring it down to
a B+ for me actually sorry guys you had
the B+
yeah they produced expend okay yeah I
just looked it up yeah they they're
Distributors for Expendables yeah okay
never mind sus guys never mind I take
back everything I said that is really
really
bad oh boy oh man they did the Now You
See Me movies dude those are great can't
wait for now you see me
three yeah they're weird cuz they just
seem to get loads of views I know you
reacted to them and it's like
people I love it when I said you guys
watch this now uh yeah they're great
they're fun they're so I just don't like
CGI magic I'm gonna watch them though
but it's you got watch it is unan it is
utterly ridiculous if whatever the P you
just got to take away all your love for
the prestige and
that's all that's the only advice I
could give you is just take away your
love for the prestige and just watch a
star studded cast do CGI magic and Go
the whole time you just be shaking your
head but you can't stop watching and
you're it is it is an unbelievably
engaging film it's like the fast x
movies Greg Fast and Furious movies you
know they're all CGI in the cars and
stuff and it's just kind of once I've
seen like real car chases you know what
I mean it's difficult for me to really
really love that stuff you gotta forget
about it you just gotta forget about
good good movies you gotta Forget About
You Gotta forget about well made Cinema
man and just and just turn your brain
it's a little definition of like look at
famous people doing CGI stuff it's it's
a great time it's a great time well look
though Paramount had a great year they
got a pretty good score with Scream Six
scream Seven's been an absolute mess um
and Christopher Landon has exited and he
said this will disappoint and Delight
others it was my dream job that turned
into a nightmare and my heart day did
break for everyone involved everyone but
it's time to move on I have nothing oh
the people are saying that
scream seven is pretty much dead and
they've came out and said look we're
just going to do a complete reboot I was
thinking Greg right and I'm I'm a genius
right I'm not really I'm a bit of an
idiot so apologies in advance guys but
you know in the scream universes right
what do they have they have those stab
movies that are like fourth wall
breaking meta commentary I was thinking
if I was put in this situation at Sky
Dan I'm like what the hell do I do I
would just make the stab
movies make put this drama in the script
of the stab movies and just constantly
take shots of how stupid everyone at Sky
Dan is it would be like it would be like
the
Matrix for whatever the hell that was
called was it the all got resur what was
The Matrix res resurrect yeah yeah yeah
because I was thinking between that and
Revolution and I couldn't quite remember
and rebooted as well I think it should
have been called the mate Ricks rebooted
but we leave that at that yeah but yeah
it's been a complete mess behind the
scenes um and yeah they just they've got
to a point now with Scream where yeah I
mean obviously Melissa Barrera ended up
getting fired NE Campbell didn't get
paid what she wanted and what I think
she deserved as well um they lost
General tiger and now yeah Christopher
Landon's gone it's kind of like
congratulations guys well done on
[__] this up amazingly you you've
somehow managed to you had a real hit on
your hand the scream franchise was back
you guys were just printing money every
yeah it just [__] it up so uh it's
pretty much dead I think they're
obviously not going to take that as a
lesson though and what they're going to
do is try and bring it back but I think
it's pretty doomed I wouldn't want the
job I who would want this job right now
I think you got to wait you got to wait
some time man I'm a huge fan at this
franchise it's my favorite horror movie
franchise you gotta wait the way how
there was time and distance between
scream four to scream
five you you got to give it the distance
now I think it's inevitable that we will
continue this
franchise I don't think it'll be with
Melissa barrera's character I don't
think you can recap ask them it's not
something scream franchise should do is
recast anyone in my opinion I don't
think they've ever done it I don't think
they ever
should and uh for something like this
you got to have a a you can't you can't
just go like come up with something you
know bring bring someone back I don't
blame this director for leaving and and
I think he's the one who did happy death
is that is that where I recognized his
name from Christopher Landon I think he
did the happy death Day
movies probably want they probably had a
really specific vision for this film
that has just been shot to [__] now
and there's too much of this negative
press around it as well you can't win
you know you just can't win you can't
have yeah you got the fans against you
no matter what they post it's like shut
down instantly and then people returning
seem like they're in support then it
creates a political conversation like it
it just creates a whole mess of things
uh this just if they just do this now so
you have to give it some you got to give
it a few years I do I do think you got
to give it some time and studios are not
known to be like yeah you know what
we'll give it a few
years but that's really the only choice
you're left with because what if you do
this I think just you're going to get a
flop on your hands like yeah you get
your movie made but you're just going to
get so much backlash and I think a big
part of horror movie franchises is is
the community around it like you could
say with any fandom sure like generally
speaking there is a fervor behind a
horror movie fandom that I think is very
integral to what gives these horror
movies legs like these movies are not
made for a lot of money and they rely on
their Audi we're just talking about
Lion's gate it made like sawx made $109
million and it's like that's [__] 10
movies in to this horror movie franchise
and like even I didn't see Insidious men
mentioned here but that did all right
and it's because of the again it's it's
like fans when it comes to the franchise
and I I feel like I feel like people
would probably opt to not show up for
this one in in some type of solidarity
against something they believe in you
know I'm not saying it's specifically
the political side it could just be for
the actors or whatever um but I I don't
think it would behoove them to make this
movie right now at least yeah and just
looking at what sky Dan own mission
impossible top gun Maverick uh
Terminator Genesis I mean Terminator
Terminator Genesis and Terminator dark
fate is you know not exactly that good
but I mean yeah just make it make a Top
Gun Sequel and put your money into that
guys put your money into that and they
also they did all the star Star Trek
reboots um the more recent ones they've
kind of flatten out now but you know
they they have got IPS that they can
easily just take the money that they
were putting into screaming take a
couple years off and put it into that I
mean and we saw something similar with
Halloween where Jam Lee Curtis was
killed off then came back and then they
had a couple of years distance in
between and they've brought her back a
couple of times I think yeah just take a
couple years off maybe try and negotiate
things with Melissa Barrera down the
line or NE Campbell or jroa and just try
and get them back involved in some way
and don't rush out with another film I
think it's just going to cause bigger
issues down the line yeah just wait for
the uh Israel Palestine conflict to end
which should be anytime soon and then
then talk with uh then talk with her
about it man because God damn The
Situation's [__] gnarly I'm really I
I mean we well Executives don't stay at
places forever either you know sometimes
people have um Ray fiser and Walter
herado was a great example of where it
was like they they were clearly arguing
and water ended up leaving I'm not
saying Ray fish is back or anything but
you know execs leave all the time and go
other places so even if she has problems
with certain Executives who fired her
you don't know who's going to be there
in five years and they might have
someone else who can come in and be like
look we're s we're re I've ju I've just
come on to this job myself recently and
I um made it my top priority to try and
sort this out with you um really sorry
about how my predecessors handle it we
would love to get you back cuz we want
to make money and we'll do whatever the
hell you want please just come back
please please please please come back
please and if you got NE camell's number
as well please give me it because I need
to call her and try and get her back I'm
begging I'm begging please I'm gonna get
fired it's my first day on the job I
want to make it good I want to look
please I can sort this out I'm getting a
bonus get get everyone sorry Ste ste's
gonna be back and David AR's gonna be
back everyone's going be back Jamie
Kennedy's coming back everyone's coming
back actually I think I think would show
up for that if they just made some crazy
ass movie French I'd be there be like
all right screw it they got me back they
got it they got everyone in this movie
even if it's [__] I just got to see
whatever This Disaster is gonna be if
they have every single famous person in
it what franchise would you want to see
scream cross over with let's play fun
fan fiction here is there one you would
want to see them cross over
with
Westworld wow what a choice like a
Westworld world that's the Scream
movies where it's like a killer it's
chasing how they have Samurai world yeah
have yeah have like a scream world I
don't know if you're joking but I'm on
board I I I can't top that at all that
is really creative seriously there's
there's a scenario here there's a what
if World here that I I'm really much on
board for that's really
creative thanks
well that's why I'm number one YouTuber
on a Friday night in thank you for that
gift thank thanks no no thank you so any
final words Greg uh no I I my final
words are I'm happy to be back here with
you thank you guys so much for being
supportive of Paul myself for those who
have welcomed me with open arms I
appreciate appreciate it and I think
we're just going to have a fun loose
year on these Pods at the end of the day
you know I was thinking about it man we
got we got a crazy year ahead of us
outside of movies we got a crazy year
incoming and all we can do is our work
here do our job here and that is just
talk like we're talking about movies and
while there can be some serious stuff
that happens behind the scenes and
whatnot it's not at the end of the day
it is movies and shows
so I just want to like have fun when we
whenever we're filming whenever we're
talking about stuff I just want to have
a good time because right now real
world's going to get uh it's going to
get intense out there and I want to make
sure that when people come here they
just know we're just shooting the [__]
just having fun talking about escaping I
know people keep ragging on us for being
negative Greg I've got a feeling that
2024 isn't going to be much better in
terms of box office and I've seen the
lineup we we will be back next week to
talk about the lineup of movies coming
over
the4 it's we're going to do it it's
pretty crazy yeah yeah cool we'll go
through all our predictions for the year
and because we didn't get to do that
last year because we hadn't invented the
podcast yet Greg we hadn't actually
invented podcasts back then we're g to
be back next week to talk about yeah all
the upcoming films um I don't think 2024
is going to be big but I think 2025 is
going to be big I think 2024 is going to
be big on TV with house the drag in the
boy season
4 Echo maybe we can talk about that next
week um but
yeah next week damn it yeah I need a new
Echo oh man just I want I wanted to have
just a super light January I just I got
sick before Christmas because like stop
get these videos done and then uh yeah I
just wanted dang it Echo got to cover
Echo I'm complaining about the most
first world problem in world I got to
cover a television show oh yeah we are
very lucky guys and we thank you for
letting us do this job um it's great
having you guys involved as well we're
sorry that we missed it you know
Christmas got in the way we did want to
do an episode but unfortunately stuff
got in the way but yeah we're happy to
be back in 2024 and greeting you guys
and we hope you you're right along with
us you better be back next week and but
every week for the next year yeah man be
trouble if you're not so yeah thanks for
joining us you guys take care so